five ten years from now we have you know
a many hundred person uh large alumni
group that is helping each other find
jobs co-founding companies
mentoring new oleam and kind of paying
forward this experience so i think there
is a long-term understanding in the
short term we had one fellow from last
year who is looking for a new job she
wrote to the the whatsapp group of the
cohort and within 10 minutes she had
five job opportunities and within one
week she had three job offers
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's meet
abby on executive director of nevo
network
abby builds networks and believes that
cohort based experiences can be
transformative she has spent the better
part of the last 20 years creating
programs that impacted hundreds of
students and fellows personal and
professional journeys whether it be
putting a roof on a home in the
aftermath of hurricane katrina or
directing leadership fellowships at duke
and harvard
since moving to israel in 2015 abby has
built two non-profits that impact the
israeli tech ecosystem currently she's
the executive director of naval network
a professional development fellowship
that helps orlin new immigrants amplify
their tech careers in israel and is
backed by michael eisenberg of alfvc
abion welcome to 20 minute leaders thank
you for joining me here how are you
i'm well thank you thank you for having
me
of course i'm looking forward to talking
to you about
cohort based experiences community
experiences your work today with with
early new immigrants to israel
integrating as part of the tech
ecosystem so doing a lot of positive
impact in our community and but also
some insights that i think are relevant
for everyone really to understand and
i'm looking forward to getting insights
myself in these next 20 minutes so abby
tell me you know where you're from
you're from the united
with st idea of cohort based experiences
sure i grew up in virginia
and when i was growing up there it
wasn't a very large jewish community but
i was both an athlete and also part of
usy which is united synagogue youth
uh which is a jewish youth movement
and i learned really early on that
there's power in community whether it's
as part of a team or as part of this
youth movement and kind of getting to
know people from
um all over the area and doing things
together and kind of building
connections that way
um and that's something that i took with
me it was always interesting the notion
of building community and leadership
development and it's something that i've
been really fortunate that i get to do
in my career
wonderful and so where did this really
start this idea of cohort based
experiences
so the first uh role that i got out of
my my second degree i did a masters in
um at brandeis university in boston and
it was
really really cold so i moved to
california and i was really fortunate to
get a fellowship doing
work on campuses on the west coast
helping students have a conversation
around israel which at that time and
still today can be really challenging
and i saw that there was really
something powerful in helping people
have conversations around something hard
and that kind of ignited my love for
working with students and people who are
going through some sort of
transformative journey
and from there i was
really really fortunate to
take over this role at hillel
international
to build this experiential learning
program that allowed 3000 students to
respond to the hurricane that hit the
gulf coast united states
um so i got to spend three years between
washington dc
and mississippi and louisiana doing this
kind of social justice experiential work
and helping students understand what
their responsibility was in the world
and why they were choosing to do this
kind of work
and at the same time trying to figure
out how to interact with the local
community
and figure out what their needs were and
how to build a program that was relevant
to them as well
incredible tell me more about about you
know these efforts after the hurricane
and what you were doing with hill
international
so hilla was really lucky to get a lot
of the money that was donated to the
jewish community and so they could build
something from scratch that kind of put
together a lot of their values which was
experiential social justice community
and we brought students from all over
north america
and we had the chance actually to train
staff also all over the country to think
about how do we interact with students
and how do we create an experience is
going to impact them
for the rest of their lives and i see it
today that people are doing this kind of
work whether it's communal work or
teaching or justice work because of the
week they spent in the gulf coast
we not only gutted homes and put roofs
on homes and and did rebuilding work but
we had really in-depth conversations
about
our own responsibility and the jewish
role of social justice and where that
lives in our modern lives and i think it
hit home for a lot of people and for me
it was by far the the best professional
experience i've had today because it
kind of set me up for understanding
the building community can be done
anywhere anytime and be really powerful
so i
i got to train my husband
no i'll say also i uh one of the one of
the staff members that i trained in that
experience turned out to be the the man
i married so it had
a doubly uh rewarding experience for me
beautiful now if you look at it from the
lenses of the students who were
undergoing this experience
what did it do to them how did you
perceive from their from their eyes you
know their journey you know working
working as a group
i think that they
they went on this experience feeling
like there was something kind of sexy
about it there was this big disaster
that had happened and they felt that it
was really um
attractive to them to respond and then
once they got there we were literally
sleeping in tents
we were
you know in in cold weather we were in
uncomfortable conditions and then doing
really hard physical labor all day and
that kind of drove home to them that it
no matter what drove them there they
really had to ask themselves what they
were doing there once they arrived
and a lot of the questions were why were
you helping people
in new orleans and in in mississippi and
not in your own backyard what does it
mean to
to respond to this kind of thing on a
daily basis where's the kind of ongoing
social justice response in your life
not only in this one week that you can
take out but in an ongoing basis and
it's something that i see that they were
able to bring back to campus with them
and then take into their everyday life
and so there was something really kind
of transformational that happened for
them
right and so today you're you're taking
those same experiences and your
understanding of building strong
communities
through the israeli tech ecosystem right
yes a little bit of a different uh
milieu but similar similar kind of
foundational thinking around it um
i was really fortunate to be connected
two years ago to michael eisenberg who
is the one of the founding partners of a
big venture capital here in tel aviv and
he's known both for that work but also
for being really really
passionate about new immigrants and and
helping them both come to israel and be
really successful here and michael and i
met and we talked about different ways
to encourage people to come to israel
which is a really big conversation right
now in general
and and we finally came around kind of
after iterating a number of times to
not necessarily encouraging people to
come off the bat but thinking really
critically about what it would mean to
create community for the people that had
already decided to move here and build
their career here
so
about two years ago we founded an
organization called novo network
which is working directly with these new
olim and helping their professional
development journey be successful in
israel and one of the really uh critical
things for that is network that you know
if you didn't um
grow up in israel if you don't
necessarily speak hebrew do university
do an army program here um then you
don't have that network that native
israelis have and network is
almost everything here and so we built
navau as a way to kind of
act um as that network that they
wouldn't have had otherwise
and in the two years that we're running
we've seen it be super successful
right so how do you
you know from how do you judge the
quality of a network so how do you go
and and how do you know whether you know
the network that you're building is
successful are there you know key matrix
that you're looking at or kpis that
you're looking at
i think recruiting and selection in
terms of the people that you're inviting
into the cohort are really critical one
we're looking for diversity in in the
second cohort we have people from 12
countries every one of their immigration
journeys was going to be really
different someone coming from russia
compared to brazil compared to the u.s
or australia
and we have people who are working all
across tech so we have engineers and
product founders people working in
venture capital and so they're kind of
seeing all the different facets of the
ecosystem and therefore they can create
a really uh dynamic conversation and
also they're each bringing their own
kind of micro network and so we're
looking for people that can kind of help
build up the cohorts network while
building their own
right and so i mean internally within
the network
how does it actually run so you have
people you know tangibly so you you you
bring people on the court then they go
work in the ecosystem but what what is
the how does the community actually form
and and what is the ongoing activity of
this network
so the people that we're inviting into
the cohort are already working they're
already employed by amazing companies
they have great roles this is really
meant to kind of help them leverage
where they're at and get to the next
stage whether that be to become a team
leader or an executive to perhaps
co-found a company um and so they're
they're often
looking to to to leverage where they're
at but what do we do we meet every two
weeks so one of the ways that we build
community is actually being together
right it seems really um intuitive and
simple but just being together and
getting to interact especially after the
last two years of spending a lot of time
on zoom and in your our homes can be
really really powerful um we connect
each fellow to a mentor to an israeli
mentor who is more senior than they are
in the ecosystem who can act as a kind
of deep relationship for them and
someone that can advise them
through kind of pivot points or career
questions
um and at the same time we we try to
build a broad and deep network and we're
connecting them to as many israelis as
possible so to anyone listening if you
want to be connected to any of our
fellows we're more than happy we're
literally trying on a daily basis anyone
i meet i'm like i have a person i want
to set you up for coffee with we're
really trying to figure out all of the
people that we can connect them to so
they walk out of the fellowship knowing
a lot more israelis than they did coming
in
they get career coaching we have
retreats
and they also work together to create
different projects with one another so
that they get to know each other deeply
and we hope one day either decide to
choose each other's co-founders or help
each other find next jobs or help each
other just kind of make hard decisions
right and so from your perspective sort
of the organizer of this how do you know
you know if a cohort was successful or
not so i think you know one of the
things that i've always been struggling
with understanding is how do i measure
the eff the efficiency or the
successfulness of a community that i'm
that i'm running right i don't know if
it's actually providing value to people
if it's actually if people are actually
want to be a part of it on truthfully so
how how do you gauge that that you know
managerial question
it's a it's a really good question and
one that i think has two answers i think
there's a short term and a long term
um i'll start with the long term the
long term is five ten years from now we
have you know a many hundred person uh
large alumni group that is helping each
other find jobs co-founding companies
mentoring new oleam and kind of paying
forward this experience so i think there
is a long-term understanding in the
short term
we had one fellow from last year who is
looking for a new job she wrote to the
the what's up group of the cohort and
within 10 minutes she had five job
opportunities and within one week she
had three job offers
she's been in israel for a year and a
half and would never have had the
ability to do something like that
otherwise
one of the other fellows just left his
current job to found his own company
when he did so he turned to michael and
said listen i think i'm ready to make
the jump and i just want to know that if
i do can you perhaps make a connection
for me can you introduce me to this kind
of person and because of the network of
people he felt confident enough after
only a few years in israel he's
originally argentinian to make a jump
and found his own company here so you
know those are the kind of anecdotal
things that tell us so we're going in
the right direction
right and then and then in the long term
in the long term we hope that you know
this is something that will
not only serve the the kind of purposes
that we just talked about which is kind
of helping people find jobs and found
companies and and act as that community
of people that can be references but it
encourages other people from around the
world to say israel's a place that i
want to work
there is an opening and welcoming
community not only of israelis but also
volime that are going to help make sure
that we have a way to be be successful
professionally this is a big question
when people are coming from outside of
israel i had it as a as an allah myself
how am i going to translate my career
from the united states to israel how am
i going to be successful am i going to
make enough money am i going to find
meaning
and
and these people if we leverage this
network and these in this community
correctly
we'll answer that question before those
people even make the decision
beautiful now from from your perspective
you know if for anybody that's looking
to create a community or start a
community what are some non-trivial
things
that you've learned you know through
your time about building successful
communities
that we can be keeping in mind
i think from the beginning to get to
know each member of the community and to
really try to figure out um and work
with them to figure out what's driving
them when we kick off nouveau we get
each of the fellows to do an exercise on
finding their why
and it's a little bit of an exercise for
us the people running the community my
partner roni and i as well as for each
of the fellows so we kind of understand
their passion and and what's pushing
them and that helps us figure out who we
connecting them to inside the fellowship
outside the fellowship
and to come with a really clear
foundational structure of what you want
to achieve and for us from a leadership
development perspective we look at
leadership of self and leadership of
teams right and then from nouveau
specifically we look at connection to
israel so everything we're doing we're
thinking really critically at are we
pushing them to to understand their
self-motivation better are we thinking
about how they interact with the cohort
and teams and are we pushing their
connection to israel and ecosystem so
that they walk away with a deeper
understanding and connection to the
people and organizations in israel
so i think for each community there are
really specific pieces that
need to be considered
that's what it sounds like and and are
there you know best practices or
standards for you know how often they
should be interacting with the community
or how often the community should be
reaching out to them you know because at
the end people are living or leading you
know complicated lives and then there
are communities that they want to be
involved in and you know you want them
to to you know be involved but but not
in a way that's that's that's
distracting them from everything else
that's going on their life but
ameliorating it right and augmenting it
so
right are there best practices to these
sorts of communications
um so we find that
because we're an in-person community
that we're we're not meeting three times
a year per se we're meeting kind of
every other week that we try to um
make sure the communication is
um
[Music]
when we're doing it it's clear it's not
too often and if it needs to be you find
kind of a captain within the community
to kind of go out and do the peer
influence rather than us being the
reminder of communication often we find
people within the community that can
push
but that more so everything we do we
make it excellent if it's excellent this
will become a priority at a place that
they want to be
if we
come in under excellent there's a
there's a percentage chance that this
becomes less of a priority so everything
we do ronnie and i push ourselves to
make sure that we're bringing the best
people to speak the best facilitators
the best experience and that's not the
kind of um
you know the tech experience where
everything is really upscale but the
content is the highest and best content
that we can give them
as it relates to the goals that we have
a hundred percent so abby what do you
get out of this so what why are you in
this
you know in this field and this work and
community building in in oleem
where where are you at
that's a great question um i i really
you know from my time in the gulf coast
to the work that i did with hillel i
worked later at duke and at harvard
again with students and i love this
moment where a person or group of people
is in transition and you can help them
think through
kind of left or right up or down i love
being involved in that moment where
someone is about to grow and you can
help them figure out what that growth
can look like i think in some ways i
feel like a catalyst in helping
in you know inspire someone to do
something rather than be the the act
itself
and for me the the notion that i get to
interact with people all the time is
really exciting that for me is kind of
what what motivates me this notion of
building community and of of getting to
really build deep relationships with
different people
right i i love it and at the end you
know i i'm always curious you know the
the community builders i mean it's such
a personality and and i always see
people getting so much satisfaction from
from building building a strong
community as they as they go through did
you know from your time you know until
international or even before that that
you're going to be dedicating a very big
part of your career to community
building and and working maybe specific
specifically with olim
i don't think that i
i don't think that i could have um
that if you asked me when i was younger
i would have known it but if i look back
i was always the one organizing things i
was always the one taking on extra i
love the kind of planning and the
connecting of people and
i don't think that i would have ever um
foretold that i'd work with olim because
i didn't know necessarily that i would
live in israel but it became really
clear to me when i got here that there
was this amazing community that
there were great things that you could
do with it the first four years i spent
as a ceo of another organization that
was bringing mbas from outside of israel
to do paid internships inside israel and
that was super exciting because it was
90 non-jews and 50 non-americans and it
was people that would have never
otherwise come to israel and so you got
to build this crazy community for three
months over the summer of people who are
kind of experiencing israel often for
the first time so that was a whole other
lens and that kind of led me to what i'm
doing now which is
there's there's this amazing opportunity
that israel provides in terms of the
tech ecosystem to build community
100 now if you had to look at you know
the work that you're doing and
extrapolate you know five ten years in
the future where is it at
it's a really good question i hope in
some ways that novo still exists i don't
know that i'll be involved in the same
role but i would love to to see that
this olim community exists
and i see myself i i feel myself growing
my own community in israel navos started
in some ways because i felt like i
didn't have my own network and so i
thought well if i don't have a network
then let me help other people build a
network it's something that my my
partner and i kind of figured out
together
and and so if i can continue doing that
for people if i continue doing this work
of interacting deeply with people then i
think i'll be really happy
beautiful
what inspires you in your day-to-day so
you know in building the community and
working with
where do you gather your own inspiration
from
so i'm the kind of person that
reads like four books at a time so i
would say um
[Music]
writing reading fiction stories i really
believe that storytelling is a powerful
tool both for
for the individual it's something that
i've used throughout my life whether
it's traveling or as an ola to kind of
connect to other people and i think it's
also a super powerful tool for
communities it's a way that people
connect to each other and so i really
love
reading fiction nonfiction as many
stories as i can get to kind of inspire
me
i love it i love it and if you had to
choose a few words
and that would describe you and perhaps
words that any of your community members
would would choose to describe abby what
words come to mind
so i think i would um
first i feel like global citizen
um i lived abroad for the first time
when i was eight
um and spent a lot of time traveling
throughout my life and moved to israel
six years ago so i feel myself kind of
somewhere between many countries
um and something that kind of my most
favorite thing to do is travel um
i think i i think you know community
builder catalyst someone that tries to
yeah to push other people to to kind of
get through the best part of their
journey
um and a storyteller i'm also a writer
and i'm someone who
really believes in the power of story
and and that's something that i see kind
of
continues
amazing abby thank you so much and not
just for these 20 minutes but for the
work that you're doing in the tech
ecosystem in israel and for the work
that you were doing with halal
international it sounds like you know
you're not just building a community but
you're building communities that make a
really positive impact um and especially
known on people that are that are in a
point of struggle that that they really
needed and so it's a it sounds like just
a huge positive impact all around and
thank you very much for joining me for
these 20 minute leaders thank you so
much for having me
appreciate it
foreign